HELD UP.
NOW THEY'RE READY TO GO.
HERE WE GO FROM DOWNTOWN
BUFFAL
INTERCEPTED, A PASS OFF THE
GOALPOST AND THEY SCORE.
THE
THIS ALLOWED SOUCYOMING BACK WI
A SHOT ON REBOUND.
IT'S ON THE GOAL LINE BUT IT MO.
HE KEEP YOURSELF IN FRONTCORE
ON THE HIS
BUFFALO BOUNCING RIGHT BACK IN
THERE AND PUTTING IT BEHIND THE.
EVERYBODY ELSE KEEPS GOING INTO
THE NET.
>> Rick: THEY SHAVED THE LEAD TO
A MORE MANAGEABLE POSITION NOW,
.
CAME OUT IN FRONT.
THE SHOT,
HERE
NOT ABLE TO GET BACK.
FIRST POWER-PLAY GOAL T THE
POINT.
SAVES MADE.
SCORE!
GETS THAT POSITION RIGHT THERE.
DOES A LITTLE MOHAWK.
GETS THAT
THEY  ABLE TO GET OVER
THERE AFTER THEY GOT PAST HIS
STICK.
POINT.
SCORE!
OKPOSO
OKPOSO WAS WAITING FOR DAHLIN TO
GET IN.
TAKES THATET
BY
THE GAME.